water taxi operator mati Nieminen can
navigate around the scary coast of
southern finland in his sleep joined by
russian born sociologist olga han onin
he's on his way to a mysterious island
that was recently the source of
controversy in finland finally they
arrived at the island circulat which
until recently was owned by a rich
russian and is now for sale their
surveillance cameras have been turned
off last autumn finished police forces
stormed the island
security experts had become suspicious
of this luxurious estate complete with
smaller surrounding islands a
conspicuous amount of jetties and a
helicopter landing pad was this set to
become a Russian espionage base after
all it's in a strategic position along
the Baltic Sea route to the west Captain
Nieminen was also surprised the capacity
I think maybe I'm 400 people but in the
middle of nowhere capella Corps with no
connections at all it's really strange
Hahnemann has researched Russian holiday
homeowners in Finland even though the
owner of this island denies any
connection to the Russian state the lack
of trust between finns and these
property owners is at an all-time high
and recently safety and security issues
has been on the surface of these
discussions especially of the after the
crimean well we have an easy historical
past between Finland and Russia and
which affects quite a lot because Russia
annexed part of Finland after the Second
World War
400 kilometers east the Finnish Russian
border at imatra most Russians crossing
the border are just going shopping at
the finished supermarket others are
looking to buy one of these holiday
homes along one of the many lakes
soon akima lenin finnish MP for the
social democrats grew up in this border
region and finds the development
worrying for years she warned others
about the unregulated buying up of real
estate by Russian nationals following a
controversy surrounding the island of
iris ttan the Finnish government
introduced restrictions the authorities
have determined that buyers from outside
the EU need a special permit to buy real
estate or property relevant to national
security
like nearby military facilities of
broadcasting towers generally this will
be prohibited in the future we should
also stress that this is a matter of
reciprocal treatment as Finn's cannot
buy real estate or property at Lake
Ladoga
or other places in Russia Finland
doesn't want to aggravate its neighbor
Russia when Russian President Vladimir
Putin came to visit Helsinki in August
the debate surrounding Russian property
and real estate owners was not part of
the agenda sociologist olga Hahn onin
has studied how Russians in Finland feel
she's observed that even though they are
increasingly rejected by their Finnish
neighbors many Russians still greatly
appreciate Finland those who own
properties in Finland they are not
afraid that Finland will confiscate or
take away the property because they
again very good image about Finland they
believe that the case will be handled
according to proper case proper rights
but there is still widespread mistrust
toward the Russian government among many
Finns
making it increasingly difficult for
Russians to buy exclusive properties in
the unspoiled landscapes of Finland